vacances est possible mal en patience
pour les automobilistes yvelinois
plusieurs travaux ont lieu cet été dans
le département le poncho l'air va être
doublée entre les communes de maurepas
et la verrière quant aux pour cache un
attrape il va être réaménagée en vue de
couvrir la nationale 10 la voirie quant
à elle n'est pas en reste quelques
kilomètres d'enrobé seront posées dans
l'agglomération
six communes sont concernées elles
encourent guyancourt magny les hameaux
montigny le bretonneux trappe et voisins
le bretonneux
les travaux commencent dès le 9 juillet
outre les automobilistes les cyclistes
ne seront pas oubliés une nouvelle piste
cyclable s'ajoutera à celles existantes
à elancourt
même chose à magny les hameaux le long
de la départementale 195
tous ces travaux devraient se terminer
d'ici à la rentrée de septembre